a game that has been out for quite some
time but not on this platform
callyblackie you've been playing a lot
of Mario Kart 8 on this year of our good
Nintendo lures Nintendo switch release
yes I have tell us about it I reviewed
it I gave it a 9 so obviously I really
liked it I'm a big Mario Kart fan I get
a little too competitive
maybe um making of this Friday we are
doing a huge tournament livestream
that's also totally tuned into I think
right now it's set for 2 p.m.
cool um so yeah come to watch me destroy
everyone um get off the set I think the
all kidding aside I think that the
biggest thing is that um I was a little
worried because I'm like okay I've
played the heck out of Mario Kart 8 on
Wii U um why should I return to this and
one of the big draws is they completely
fixed battle mode and that was a big
focus of my review because the racing is
very similar it's still super great
racing but the battle mode was like so
underwhelming on Wii U and they just
completely changed it and added actual
battle levels and what you're seeing
here is you know a return to form like
if you were a fan of like the n64 hood
um bad super fun like there's this bomb
not just metal mode where it's just like
so chaotic um don't worry for much fun
is it different take on like when you
know if you died if you played four to
three people in 64 you became a bomb is
it similar to that no it's you all item
boxes are bombs you can carry up to like
ten bombs at once and your goal is to
pop everyone's balloon so it's like a
variation of balloon battle which was
the only mode available on the Wii U
version and all the tracks were actual
race tracks so it didn't really work
very well this one is just like you're
in these yours choke points and there's
like central areas where like [ __ ] goes
down and it got really chaotic and we
may be yelled while we were capturing
all of this it's good sign so very much
sounds like it's worth returning to so
like you said even though you played a
lot on Wii U you still found this
- come back - so how much of that is the
fact that it's an obvious I don't think
this plan into your review about how
much of that is the fact that it's not
like the one game you're playing on a
switch anymore it's not just Zelda you
have something else that kind of shows
the switch is fun like um that doesn't
really have anything to do with it cuz I
do have other games on switch that I'm
playing yeah um it's more I think the
like switch technology this is sort of
weird thing that maybe not everybody
would notice but playing it I am a
really big fan of drifting as you can
see from any of this capture and the the
vibration and the joy Khan's is actually
so responsive and it feels much more
satisfying to execute actually um and I
was surprised by that I didn't think I
would notice that as much but it looks
great and it feels great to play mhm um
and for me that was like oh now I feel
more rewarded going back to these that
I've already you know on Wii U I got
three stars on every mode every cup and
all the DLC and all that and this was
like oh I got to do that again I got to
unlock all these car parts again but it
was actually really rewarding to do and
part of that was the feedback and I'm
gonna get blue shell oh no not um yeah
and then the other thing is uh I I guess
you do have a point that switch it's not
that I'm like oh now I have something
else to play on switch but I do think
switch is a fantastic platform yeah and
for a Mario Kart especially I I really
like Mario Kart 7 on 3ds also just
because I like to the portability factor
and being able to carry this around and
we even did in the office already at her
and she should bumped you off uh yeah I
I was like I'm gonna get fired cuz I'm
trash talking too much
um and then that happened um no I I like
like in the office we were able to set
the switch down we didn't have it docked
and we played four players split-screen
yeah that was bonkers and it hurt really
bad because you drifting on the joy the
joy counts it's really hard so and you
had like a 2 inch screen - yeah this is
a stake in your palm and your back hurt
from punching over trying to get
was hunching over a desk but what I like
the point of that anecdote is that it's
that factor is like oh it adds this new
kind of way to play and coupled with
battle mode it's kind of like
rediscovering what I liked about this
game originally so ho-ho miiine I know a
in the YouTube chat was asking if you
use the pro controller at all for this
for this capture I did okay uh when my
regular playing I don't actually own a
pro controller um so I didn't for the
review or any of the normal gameplay I
did you got some drifting skills that's
deaf someone was saying that in the chat
yeah I be drifting in real life though
so oh yeah they call me trivia waluigi
i'm excited i never i was not a wii u
owner and i love mario kart uh namely
six-four obviously like so many people
and so yeah like this is this is
probably the the real first multiplayer
experience for the switch like yeah
absolutely like I'm I'm excited to like
actually play with other people and not
for players split screen on one rip my
screen but yeah like in the office this
should be fun and Friday as well that's
great yeah came in I came at a good time
because I mean I still love playing
Zelda but um aside from other things
I've tried on it like like snipper clips
but I mean I'm right looking forward to
splatoon too and I think it like you
just said Robin sort of multiplayer that
Mario Kart 8 is you could do a lot worse
this is I mean this is the the test run
right for multiplayer on switch we'll
see how it works
aside from battle were there any other
smaller quality-of-life improvements on
the switch aside from just making use of
the like joy cons and whatnot yeah yeah
I probably should have mentioned that
they added you can hold two items at
once so it has this little double dash
flavor which I like one of the things
about the Wii U version is it was very
racing focus and I like that
I think the racing is really strong and
it's the best Mario Kart in a while but
having more items really keeps you on
your toes there's just more items being
thrown at you and that can get
frustrating but like I was just getting
hit by shells left and right and it um
added another dimension of challenge
like I feel like I've already mastered
these tracks and then
now I have to kind of adopt a new
strategy and like I built a cart with
better acceleration so I could recover
from shells and stuff like that so I
think that's a small small enough change
load times are a lot shorter and there
was another thing how's the frame rate
but I don't know technical details y'all
yeah benchmark this I'm just I'm just
kidding telling about that frame rate
and I'm assuming there are new maps and
whatnot there is no new tracks for Grand
Prix like regular racing all the battle
mode maps are new and actually worked
for battle the characters are already
unlocked and all the tracks and DLC is
already unlocked some people I talked to
were not stoked about that but I think
you also have to still unlock your cart
customization so there's still level of
progression there that's kind of the one
thing that was a little bit of a I don't
know not everybody I talked to you was
super stoked about that and really here
though I think a lot of us prefer to
play a multiplayer but when you're
playing solo did you prefer to have a
doc door did you like it handheld or um
my friends played it mostly handheld I
want I just that's just my thing I love
playing handheld does it take the like
motion controls into play outside of the
joy cons at all um I don't see Mario
Kart with motion control no um I'll bump
or drift in for you oh yeah hell yeah I
thought you'd have something funny Oh
bump robbers color commentary where's
that dress we haven't gone to world war
ii 7y Wacka cool I vote Jesus okay cool
so yeah Callie's review is up on games
fire now you can go read it Mario Kart 8
for the switch she gave it a 9 out of 10
final thoughts and play it yes you
should play it if you haven't played it
or if you thought you were done on the
Wii U version you should still play it
if you have a switch cool and like we
said Friday we think 2 p.m. Pacific
we're going to start doing like an hour
hour and a half tournament kind of like
the rocket League 1 we did except not
stretch over a month although that was
fun if you're if you're a GameSpot fan
we did that last year but this one will
be a day thing what's what does the
winner get honor if we decided yet and
that's not good no I think there wasn't
very much for honor I was talk of a
trophy there was time
trophy I hope it's beer just a trophy
made of beer or play for a beer trophy
or just beer just beer probably maybe
their beer
regardless I'm hoping I'm hosting I mean
I'm announcer yeah you're like I'm so
excited for that are you gonna dress up
do it I got a NASCAR commentator just
you know I had a coming off the corner
however coming off like an auctioneer
except about cars hey come on
oh my god can't she get on that note
covered in spit eardrums bleeding we're
gonna move on the next segment but let
us know if you plan to return tomorrow
car 8 if you have a switch do you want
to return to it do you want to get a
switch just to play this if you don't
already want a free cell die or
something like that splatoon - or Super
Mario ah - see you later in the year let
us know what you think in the comments
below
[Music]